what is happening there citizens of the reject
Nation you're looking at the three biggest Wonka
fans right now joined by John how are you
I'm feeling sweet koi unironically one of
my most anticipated of the Year koi when is our
Comic-Con panel that the real rejects is having
1 p.m Saturday this July something that's my
second that's what I'm talking about people
wow looking at what Timothy chalamet is wearing
in this thumbnail he is dressed like a sexy dog
I'm I'm transitioning to something guys
my feathered rejects today I've got a
tail waggingly good Scoop for you let's talk
about our sponsor bird dogs I'm wearing them
comfortable pants right now but also they have
their shorts that'll have you looking fetching
these shorts are no bird brainers my friends
let me show you they're designed to fit Slimmer
through the thigh and the leg giving you a truly
possum sculpted look they do everything Lululemon
does but with an extra wag in their tail so
say goodbye to those rough cotton shorts bird
dogs fix that Mudder by creating their Cloud
knit fabric I mean come on it looks as sharp
as khaki but stretches like a dog chasing its
tail you just gonna waste them or fit without
being you know leash stricted got these puns going
people here's the cherry on top or should I say
the bird on the wire when you order from bird
dogs.com using my special code rejects you'll
fetch a free Yeti style tumbler it's the perfect
companion for hydrating on your adventures
Grandpa's medicine so don't sit on the perch
my pals hurry over to birddogs.com rejects
to unleash the possum power of these
shorts and snag your free Yeti style
Tumblr trust me once you experience the
comfort and style you'll be barking about
bird dogs to all your buddies they really
are comfortable and a lot of people want
to know what are some of the best ways to
support the channel one of the best ways to
get yourself some bird dogs by getting your
tail wagon head to birddogs.com rejects now
I've spent the past seven years
traveling the world perfecting
my craft doing Australia something of a
magician inventor and chocolate maker so
quiet up and listen down nope scratch
that reverse it is what are you doing
I'm making chocolate of course how do you
like it dark white nutty absolutely insane
dark absolutely insane so chocolate they've
all been crushed by the chocolate carts
and you can't sell chocolate without a shop
no daydreaming
huh huh
a double heart do the pencil
on paper uh-huh I got an idea
he's like the human Paddock didn't have been
easy for you they're gonna get better you promise
I promise that's the most solemn
vow there is where do we started
what's happening oh that's a chocolate
that makes you fly let's find out shall
we who's forever John what's up that
Harry Potter touch burp Charlie small
group of people defined in the laws what a
cast and we had Olivia Coleman earlier too
about 150 pounds in the last two weeks
change her life change all their lives don't get
visuals in here man yeah a nice one started with
a dream it's a world of Pure Imagination
you hold on to yours yeah there we go mama
mark my words this is gonna be the greatest
chocolate shop the world has ever seen
all right shell made a funny little
man there he is no there he is foreign
oh that's hilarious you know I gotta say I gotta
say that kind of looks like you know when Disney
was doing those live action sequels or prequels it
kind of looked like that but with the production
quality of a Harry Potter film and I feel like
chalamet is probably going to do a pretty good job
I mean he seems like he's doing a bit of a hybrid
blend of what what Johnny Depp did in Charlie and
the Chocolate Factory and from the clips I've
seen of Gene Wilder I've never actually seen the
Willy Wonka movie if that's a fun fact about Greg
never saw that one so yeah I mean I thought this
was a fun trailer this was nice based off of your
reaction I feel like you actually know this [__]
I mean yeah I'm I'm cautiously optimistic about
this this was I thought this was a solid first
trailer this doesn't like I grew up with the movie
I grew up with the book I saw the Johnny Depp one
at some point so he knows it too yeah so yeah
I'll cover Ahsoka later yeah this is certainly
going for something you know obviously sweet and
heartwarming and you know it's telling that they
got the Paddington director I associate Roald
Dahl with a certain amount of like Rye orneryness
that I'm curious to see how and if they will
incorporate so much into this movie because I know
they've said they want this to be like you know
a warm and uplifting film and it's like a full-on
musical um so yeah this is like actually a little
bit more centered in like you know the cartel and
in the city than I expected I I thought they would
lead more with like just full-on swashbuckling
Adventure or whatever but it it certainly got
me consciously optimistic I like the production
values and the costumes and the look of everything
koi please Paddington one and two are two of the
rare five star films of my heart I've ever seen
them koi never seen the paddingtons I'm missing
out on a lot of these things wow paddington's
forever I've said it before and I'll say it again
I've ridden 4 000 films I've given 23 5 star two
of them are Pat I've got some movies to add to my
reactions Paddington I I truly feel are two of the
most heartwarming films of all time so this was
really high up in my most anticipated list because
it does look like it's Timothy Charlemagne as the
Paddington character like he's he's got that
Whimsy he's got that heart he's got that wonder
he's got that like splendiferous sense of awe
but you add you juxtapose perhaps you have some
dichotomy Duality uh with Roald Dahl's Darkness
it's duplicitousness of the Roald Dahl Paddington
dichotomy is really what intrigues me but I I
really think that Roald Dahl's cantankerousness is
so wonderful and there's something that makes you
laugh while you're like man this is dark that I
think is really unique specifically to Willy Wonka
in the Chocolate Factory so I love the idea of
Like An Origin before he kills all those kids so I
think it's going to be a really fun movie they're
not alive anymore because of things he said those
kids aren't not murdered children so I think this
looks really sweet and wonderful and then I I
do agree there was a lot of the Harry Potter
um sense of scope and sense of awe so I really it
looks like a greatest hits for that really warm
feeling you want over the holidays this being
the Christmas movie of the year it feels like
I mean I'd rather have this be the new Harry
Potter than rehashing Harry Potter this looks
great to me what I was kind of craving from
this trailer though because yeah you want to
reintroduce into the world you want to show you
want to give a good visual sense of the tone and
the aura and the mood I want to get a little bit
more of the musical inclinations though that they
were hinting at I wanted to kind of get a tease
of what you know Timothy chalamet's voice might
ultimately sound like what he's saying I'm not
has he done a musical before I'm not familiar I
think that's my knowledge does he sing the
Army Hammer and call me by your name yeah
each um but what I also really wanted is to sort
of get this sense of like rooting for for Wonka
since this is supposed to be because in the in the
Willy Wonka story you know he is the mysterious
figure who knows more than everyone else and then
you're finding out what his master plan is as you
slowly uncover some of his backstory right and
then here I wanted to kind of get a sense of
like I want to see some of that weird eccentricity
in the the awkwardness and some of the troubling
upbringing that the guy had as well but get a
sense of like really rooting for him since he
is the main character we're going to root for
this time you know and but right now it's the
first trailer and as the first trailer goes uh
I thought it was Charming it was delightful what
did you guys think about chalamet's first look do
you think he's gonna live up to the Wilder do you
think he's gonna live up to the depth chewing
gum is really aggressive depths the wildness of
Wilder the chalamet peaches leave your thoughts
down below people well leave a like subscribe
keep a lookout for a Comic-Con panel if you're
going to Comic Con well let's end this with a
I wanted to shout out Andrew Hayes Andrew if
there's someone I would love to Delight in
eating a bunch of chocolate with I feel like
it would be you man there's just something
about you where you're already kind of like a
squirrely little guy and I think that if we were
just getting a sugar rush together it could just
escalate into like the most semi cocaine filled
kind of conversations but just rooted in sugar
and all kinds of high you know fructose corn
syrup type of neurotic conversations that I feel
like we could really have together so Andrew I
hope that the next time you're out in California
it's around Halloween time so we could just get
all sugary Goods up in this hizzy my friend I
love you thank you for never unpleasing thank
you for never sending us any messages in the
past couple years and you've been one of our
highest pledges since I'm pretty sure your card
is just on auto repeat every month and you have
no idea I hope it's your parents credit card and
I love that about you my friend we'll talk soon